[Music]
are you tired kind of really we just got
here man
hey guys so today Isaac and I are
exploring the Huntington Library it's
our very first time that we get to come
to this beautiful place and it's so
funny because we live so close to this
place but we've never ever ever once
been here ever but today we actually
became members so I'm excited to bring
Casey here cuz Casey has never been here
how do you like it so far better it
looks amazing I know in the Japanese
garden right now and this view right
here is so he's spectacular
yeah Casey's missing out today he's
having a location scouting day with wax
okay and some other production people
because they're working on a music video
so he is missing out on this beautiful
adventure but it's okay we became
members today so we'll be back right
baby haha right let's keep exploring
oh cool oh that's so cool even though my
mind yeah you're in Japan right now we
could feel like we're with them heizak
this is so pretty and we said the same
thing but not at the same time Oh check
this out
ah does this remind you Japan yeah you
took photos a joke right it likes a
little bows it what was that place was
it bells or was it well bill wells or
belts well it was like an ancient town
huh yeah oh I found that thing that's
all red then you get to be the leader
take me where you want to go the way and
that bridge no it's clothes thing in
this bridge is crazy
well we could go over this bridge oh
look there's koi fish oh wow look at
this view this camera does not do it
justice I can tell you that right now
you want to pet a koi fish yeah you're
so cute they probably think we're gonna
be bumpy Oh cute oh the junket you know
that scared me dude I give this a little
ah yeah they're all coming here cuz they
think we're gonna feed them now I feel
bad with my food well Gail we feed them
koi fish food yes you're so pretty I
want to bring a blanket next time and
then have like a little picnic with
Daddy that'll be fun right well here's a
little waterfall that it's good
so tranquil right you feel relaxed is
the things with me no no no it's to
business you know it's funny
Isaac and I we brought our books because
we were planning on just laying in the
grass and just enjoying the nature and
just read some books but then we
realized wait this is our first time
coming how about we explore for the
first time in the next time we come we
can just sit around and read a book cool
bamboo tunnel wow this is so cool you're
like a panda
[Music]
the Chinese are pretending pardon this
is gorgeous
we should be the channel
[Music]
you want to go to Australian Gardens the
desert garden yeah let's do it
this is a really nice place I can't
believe it took us this long to finally
come and visit it
we've lived nearby for like how many
years like four years we've never been
here I feel like we've been missing out
all this time we pass by here like wow
every day huh yeah almost every day
we've passed by this place we've never
been here until now
hey remember Mexico oh dang that was
really close it was really really close
come on everybody
stay on the path the path of the path of
success stay on the path of success
[Music]
I wouldn't touch that if area uh-uh
you shouldn't go home with a whole bunch
of thorns what if you accidentally slip
forward and then you get your whole face
thorny Oh a thorny face that that
wouldn't be good right this does it that
we're in twelve thirteen what does that
mean
[Music]
soak it all in Vivek it's soaked in the
nature
[Music]
they look so worried fluffy like you
just makes you want to just jump on top
of them huh yeah I'd be a bad idea huh
animal goes like Oh for anything oh no
oh yeah
[Music]
I know it's looks like a wake up Hawaii
use you go back to miss Molloy
that's how yourself out perfect I know
you can't rest
you gotta keep running tears here they
got the right idea every parent knows
that whenever there's an opportunity for
the kids to just go wild it's like you
have to savor that opportunity to make
sure that the kids really spend and
waste their entire energy because then
at night time they'll be knocked out man
I'm tired to him I think I'm gonna be
knocked out sooner than Isaac yeah
there's a workout you lost the kid where
do you go there he is
[Music]
YouTube the patches ground to roll on
what your one is what back down we just
came from there yeah ah you just go this
way yeah you can't kick the passes okay
we need some water we got to remember
next time we come to bring some water
[Music]
all right now we're having lunch
lemonade I got some ceviche and coke
just enjoying her mother and son date
today do you like hanging out with your
mom I better say yes
[Music]